oh
foreign
so
it is inconceivable it's absolutely
impossible that the footage on which the
israeli propaganda was basing its false
claims
could in no shape or form have depicted
gunfire
there is no line of sight between one
location and the other and in fact our
researcher it has taken him a few
minutes to walk from one location to the
other location
so it's absolutely clear there is no
question about it the footage on which
the israeli government based its false
claim does not show gunfire that has
killed children
and injured her colleague
hello
[Music]
the announcement on an investigation is
one of israel's most tried and
unfortunately successful tricks in the
blanket impunity that israel provides
itself israel does not investigate
israel whitewashes and the investigation
is just the first part rather the
announcement on the investigation
is just the first stage in this
whitewash the investigations are not
meant to establish accountability they
are meant to protect the perpetrators